and not only do I contradict the notion
of many paths to the same Summit
but I I go into much more detail for
example I
tried to uh
demonstrate that a scaton of
Christianity which is called salvation
is the polar opposite
of of
the neuronic
goal there are many words you can use to
describe it in the Ved in Vedic terms
let's call it the nirvonic state
salvation and the neuronic state are the
complete opposite
why
because in the neuronic state the human
person
has disappeared
The Vedic paths the the many Vedic paths
to lesser ends but the Supreme Vedic
path
in surpass which requires the immolation
of the human being
this is why if you go to India
the sadhus they all wear Geral
that is the color that identifies the
sadhu and well
in a country that burns the bodies of
the Dead
it is easy to see that the girl or color
Bears a reference to the self-immolation
and incidentally living with facados for
seven months as I did I came to
experiences I saw that this is what
these men were doing it was a
self-immolation
and I admire them tremendously I mean
just the strength that it needs
to rise above all our human uh
proclivities to give that all up to
literally as it were take our body and
consign it to the Flames this is what
they do
and uh
my hat off to them and I know of them
dearly I love them dearly because
they were so kind to me
they could they
they immediately read all my mind and
whatever is even beneath the mind I
wrote an open book to them
uh this is automatic if you arise to
authentically a high spiritual levels
everything here in this world becomes an
open book
when you look at the person you can tell
his future and his past
everything because it
in the uh if Eternal State everything is
here now
so
by the grace of God I got a glimpse of
the greatness of the Hindu sadhus they
are giants
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy